fans seem to really want Eleanor and
tejani to get it all and we have
actually fan art they've devoted a lot
of the others fan art I think let's take
a look here people fans are really
pushing to this now this looks like
tejani is invading your space yeah no no
no it looks similar to what I drew but
you're dressed
[Laughter]
I draw things we have another one here I
mean fans are really going for it that's
really sweet that's a nice one I think
there's a final one they're just buns
baby it's not something that could ever
happen on the show make sure is here
we're giving him ideas there's nothing
that could happen well we've certainly
alluded to it a lot of times now
attracted Eleanor is to tejani
although I believe the consensus was
there's not really a reason it's not a
pivotal point in the story to define
either person's sexuality and it almost
just seems like indulgent and not
necessary to go into it like why do we
have to define what Eleanor is attracted
to maybe Eleanor is just attracted to
who she's attracted to and tejani is
gorgeous and so she keeps mentioning it
so I think yeah Eleanor is kind of
by-and-bye with me
[Applause]